hypothetical question for you
have you ever seen a group of trees
going for a swim
or gazelles that do uh this
or a um you know one of those
if you find these images baffling you're
not alone
this is codex seraphinianus
one of the most unusual books ever
written originally published in 1981
it's not an easy book to track down
written by surreal artist luigi serafini
the book is designed to be completely
alien to anyone who picks it up
the world of impossibilities within at
first
doesn't seem to follow any logic not
only are the images utterly mind-bending
but it's written in a made-up and
thoroughly untranslatable language
and yet the more you read the more you
might find a strange sense of continuity
among the images
that's because sarafini intended this
book to be
an encyclopedia an encyclopedia of a
world
that doesn't exist
[Music]
so for this entry into the archive i'm
going to do my best to document
the alternate dimensions sirfini created
bearing in mind
the codex is by design meant to be
untranslatable
so let's get started like a real
encyclopedia the book is divided into
sections
the first one seems to be on plants and
they certainly aren't any kind we'd
recognize
one page displays alien fruits and
vegetables
some of which seem to be hybrids of more
familiar produce you might find in a
grocery store in
our world or hybrids of produce and
inanimate objects
oh and watch out for trees in this realm
it seems they tend to run away
continuing our psychedelic tour the next
section is on animals
we've got some very unusual species of
birds
some fish which look like watchful eyes
peering out at you
and uh this guy who seems to
burrow underground the codex also goes
into microorganisms
tiny species which are impossible to
categorize
and seem to emerge from a gigantic
rainbow
we're just gonna have to roll with that
one the next section is on legs
just pairs of legs with peculiar objects
emerging from where the torso should be
and it seems like there's a lot of them
in this alternate dimension
sometimes the legs walk in the park
sometimes the legs walk
in the street look i'm not going to
pretend i understand this section but
there's something about it i do find
strangely hilarious the next section is
also difficult to categorize but seems
to dive into the world of chemistry and
fascinatingly subatomic particles within
these pages you can find
rows and rows of molecules which feel so
scientific
of course like the rest of the book all
this is made up
but there's something about going all
the way down to the atomic level
that makes this fictional realm feel
strangely real
next we have a short section on vehicles
like this car
made out of flies and white goo or this
other vehicle made out of
something or this cloud-shaped vehicle
which in another section
can be seen making rainbows although it
seems to
mess them up on occasion continuing on
the next and by far the largest section
is
on the people who inhabit this world or
as
close to people as this world seems to
get and i will say
the people of this alternate dimension
do seem to know how to throw a party
whether it be doing well this
or doing this honestly with most of
these
your guess is as good as mine and the
final few sections are just completely
incomprehensible
i feel like serafini wanted to make sure
no overthinkers like me
would ever be able to puzzle this world
out completely so he filled the ending
with stuff that would take
centuries to understand and with a final
page which seems like a back of book
glossary although it's impossible to
translate we've reached the end of the
codex
so stepping back from all this madness
what is sarafini trying to get at with
showing us this glimpse into another
world
well as trippy and somewhat unsettling
as some of these images are
there's also a strange sense of beauty
to the drawings
and an enthralling feeling of genuine
mystery
in the end i think codex seraphinianus
captures a
feeling the experience of reading it
reminds me of being young and flipping
through an encyclopedia
staring at pictures and not
comprehending the words but feeling a
strange
untranslatable world hovering just
outside my understanding
so maybe it's okay that we can't puzzle
out sarafini's one-of-a-kind masterwork
maybe some things are best if left truly
unexplicable
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
entry please lend your
support and like subscribe and hit the
notification icon to stay up to date on
all things curious
see you in the next video
[Music]
you